[Applauso]
ci sentiamo al sicuro quando passeggiamo
per le nostre città
alzi la mano chi pensa che la sicurezza
sia qualcosa di esterno alla nostra
persona mi spiego meglio
immaginiamoci di passeggiare in mezzo a
times square
oppure tra le strade malfamate del bronx
le differenze ci sembreranno oggettive
il primo posto è certamente più sicuro
del secondo
siete d'accordo siamo portati quindi a
pensare che la sicurezza sia qualcosa di
legato al contesto in cui ci troviamo
alla strada che stiamo percorrendo ma se
vi dicessi invece che le statistiche ci
indicano che è proprio nei luoghi più
affollati che c'è la maggior incidenza
di reati sareste disposti a cambiare
idea
oggi la comunicazione istituzionale sta
ponendo la sicurezza sempre più in
risalto pensiamo ai temi della gestione
della gestione delle folle oppure alla
movida torinese ma è la stessa cosa
anche in altre città europee
immaginiamoci i continui dibattiti che
ci sono sull'autodifesa la difesa
personale per esempio consideriamo
l'attenzione per le barriere
architettoniche
oppure la necessità di posizionare dei
parapetti sui dislivelli
esiste però una sic un'altro tipo di
sicurezza è una sicurezza che potremmo
definire soggettiva e una sorta di
realtà personale e l'idea che tutti noi
ci facciamo nella testa di un
avvenimento di un luogo che può anche
essere diverso dal
lo stesso la cosa certa però che è
diverso in maniera unica per ciascuno di
noi e si discosta in base alle nostre
caratteristiche
noi abbiamo approfondito proprio queste
caratteristiche è ciò che ne è emerso è
che la sicurezza di un luogo passa per
forza indissolubilmente dall'idea che
noi ci facciamo di quel luogo da quello
che ci abbiamo in testa da come questo
ci permette di vivere quel luogo
in altre parole dipende da noi per
questo proviamo a ricordarci a pensare
alla nostra quotidianità alla nostra
routine
questa è la strada che percorrono a
piedi tutti i giorni per andare al
lavoro
però voi potete pensare a quella che va
verso la palestra oppure so che qualcuno
di voi avrà dei figli sicuramente
pensate a quella che va alla scuola dei
vostri bambini
ci sentiamo al sicuro
personalmente sì perché dopo che l'ho
percorsa per praticamente più di quattro
anni
conosco a memoria le dinamiche che la
regolano anche le persone che ricorrono
perfino la posizione dei negozi che la
animano e sono certo che anche per voi
possa essere così
immaginiamoci adesso però che questo sia
il centro di una città che però non
conosciamo ci sono le vetrine addobbate
vabbè per il natale in questo periodo
immaginiamoci che c'è anche il
chiacchiericcio delle persone che stanno
facendo shopping e magari anche l'odore
delle caldarroste
anche qua ci sentiamo al sicuro
probabilmente sì ma allora che cos'è che
ci rende sicuri
il fatto di essere da soli o non esserlo
la luce che magari adeguata e ci
permette di vedere semplicemente dove
mettiamo i piedi oppure i suoni ei
rumori che ci sono nell'aria
magari le canzoncine di natale
personalmente no
bene signori abbiamo visto prima che
tutti noi abbiamo un filtro percettivo e
questa nostra sicurezza è influenzata
per forza da quello che vediamo è quello
che sentiamo nell'ambiente circostante
walk sales project il nostro progetto è
nato apposta per capire in che maniera
in che modo
avevamo l'obiettivo di aiutare le
persone che volevano camminare la città
di sera a farlo in maniera tranquilla
senza preoccuparsi volevamo fornire uno
strumento che aiutasse la città ad
essere progettata meglio volevamo
diffondere i temi della sicurezza urbana
che per noi sono fondamentali per fare
questo siamo andati dal comune di torino
in persona vabbè e ci ha suggerito
quattro luoghi che secondo lui sono
particolarmente critici sia in periferia
ma anche abbastanza centrali come san
salvario per esempio siamo andati a
visitarli e abbiamo chiesto l'opinione
delle persone che abbiamo trovato lì di
sera e contemporaneamente abbiamo
raccolto dei dati dei dati oggettivi di
luce di suono per le nostre ricerche
pensate che il nostro è il primo studio
multidisciplinare che considera tutto
questo insieme l'aspetto architettonico
la luce il suono il degrado la qualità
naturalmente di tutto questo ma anche
l'opinione delle persone sui social
pensate
dalle nostre ricerche è emerso che
risale al 1800
un forte legame tra preoccupazione e
contesto ed è proprio per questo che
secondo noi è la figura dell'architetto
che si deve fare carico di questi temi
importanti la domanda di sicurezza è
sempre più pressante e richiede come
abbiamo visto un contributo della
progettazione urbana e quindi compito
nostro di garantire il diritto alla
città e diritto alla sicurezza
per fare questo oltre ai dati che
abbiamo raccolto personalmente ci siamo
avvalsi di altri di in stat del comune
di torino stesso ma anche di ricerche
scientifiche autorevoli tuttavia sono
proprio i dati soggettivi i fattori
soggettivi ad influenzare la nostra
percezione di sicurezza magari proprio
le canzoni di natale
adesso questo non lo sappiamo però noi
abbiamo investigato quali tra questi
fattori soggettivi influenzano
maggiormente tutti noi siamo tutti
d'accordo sul fatto che è una donna si
senta più insicura rispetto ad un uomo e
siamo tutti d'accordo sul fatto che il
fattore della sicurezza è importante
essenziale per una donna ma questo non
dipende solamente dai recenti fatti di
cronaca
dipende anche dal contesto dall'ambiente
in cui ci si trova
per quanto riguarda gli uomini invece la
sicurezza degli uomini dipende dal
fattore distruzione dal livello
d'istruzione un uomo più e istruito più
si sente insicuro
forse perché la conoscenza e la
consapevolezza ci permettono di
comprendere appieno di capire
determinate dinamiche degli ambienti che
conosciamo ma anche degli ambienti che
non conosciamo
oltre a questi dati che noi abbiamo
identificato sul genere
ma diamo anche identificato dei dati dei
dati che influenzano un po la conoscenza
del luogo ovvero noi abbiamo detto che
il per l'uomo è importante il fattore di
istruzione quindi l'istruzione conosce
un determinato luogo
in realtà tutti noi quando ci troviamo
in un contesto in realtà in un tex
percepiamo la realtà in maniera diversa
in maniera falsata rispetto a quella che
realmente rispetto a come stiamo
effettivamente vivendo quel luogo
forse perché effettivamente conosciamo
il luogo in cui ci troviamo forse perché
percorriamo una determinata strada più e
più giorni
oppure forse perché come diceva prima
alfredo sono quattro anni che vado al
lavoro percorrendo sempre la stessa
strada
bene questa sono io nella strada che
alfredo percorre tutti i giorni magari
un luogo che per lui è molto sicuro e
maggiormente sicuro perché appunto lo ha
vissuto e rivissuto per tanti anni non
lo è per qualcun altro non lo è per me
per esempio perché non vado spesso lì
non ci vado tutti i giorni e quindi
tutti noi siamo più sicuri tanto più
conosciamo il luogo tanto più conosciamo
la realtà che ci circonda la realtà che
ci circonda può anche essere una realtà
degradata infatti il degrado
architettonico e il degrado urbano
l'aspetto architettonico che dicevamo
prima è molto importante per la nostra
percezione perché noi percepiamo quel
luogo in un modo e quindi di conseguenza
percepiamo anche la sicurezza in un modo
infatti abbiamo dimostrato che quando un
luogo a un ottima pulizia degli spazi o
un'ottima conservazione degli edifici
nel senso che gli edifici non sono
degradati viene percepito come più
sicuro rispetto ad un luogo che ha
invece una zona degradata
questo è sempre un parere del tutto
personale perché noi poniamo come
confronto le realtà che conosciamo
quindi poniamo come confronto anche il
degrado che conosciamo
magari
la zona in cui stiamo maggiormente
durante la giornata
bene oltre a questi fattori che ho
elencato finora ci sono anche dei
fattori più tecnici dei fattori come la
luce i suoni la facilità di
percorrimento di una determinata zona
che ci permettono di viverla e di
identificarla in maniera totalmente
diversa rispetto anche ad un'altra zona
molto simile rispetto ad una zona simile
ma con caratteristiche diverse
la passerella olimpica per esempio una
delle zone che abbiamo analizzato a un
po queste luci ambient un po soft che
considerando la nel contesto buio in cui
è inserita
viene percepita come più insicura
rispetto al campus luigi enaudi questa
realtà è solo l'aspetto della luce che
ci permette già di dire che è un
ambiente percepito come buio o monotono
e un ambiente più insicuro rispetto ad
un ambiente con un'adeguata
illuminazione oppure un'illuminazione
accattivante e stimolanti vivace
oltre a questo aspetto della luce
abbiamo anche l'aspetto del suono ovvero
tutti i suoni che noi sentiamo nel
contesto un suono come un classe un
improvviso durante la notte oppure il
rumore di fondo delle auto del traffico
ci creano del disagio ci fanno sentire
più insicuri mentre il chiacchiericcio
delle persone ci calma e ci rende più
rilassati
quindi da questo è possibile dire che la
piacevolezza di un ambiente sonoro
deriva dalla presenza di suoni naturali
come il vento tra le foglie oppure di
suoni antropici come appunto il
chiacchiericcio delle persone o la
risata di un bambino
bene noi oggi abbiamo imparato tre cose
che la sicurezza reale è completamente
diversa dalla sicurezza percepita e la
sicurezza dipende da ognuno di noi ma
dipende soprattutto dal contesto in cui
ci troviamo dall'ambiente in cui ci
troviamo e dalle rispettive
caratteristiche
siamo quindi consapevoli di quel
che influenza il nostro filtro
percettivo e che questo dipende non solo
da come noi percepiamo la città ma anche
da come la città è stata progettata e di
conseguenza è importante la parte della
progettazione della città perché
comunque è importante anche a facilitare
il vivere la città senza essere affetti
da bobby e il fatto di modificare anche
solo le caratteristiche ambientali come
la luce e suono per noi ovviamente le
caratteristiche ambientali sono molto
importanti perché siamo degli architetti
però per voi sono molto importanti
perché siete e in fondo anche noi siamo
dei cittadini e il garantire il diritto
alla città che dicevamo prima comunque
all'inizio di questo talk abbiamo
sentito tutti i suoni della passerella
olimpica e tutti ci siamo fatti delle
delle idee abbiamo provato delle
sensazioni
però magari dopo tutti i fattori che vi
abbiamo elencato vi renderete conto che
non è proprio la stessa sensazione per
ognuno di voi magari il vostro vicino ha
provato qualcosa di completamente
diverso da voi
quindi noi adesso siamo in un contesto
controllato e sicuro però immaginatevi
come potrebbe essere un tedesca in un
contesto buio e rumoroso
[Applauso]